more than 130 years ago before the
advent of streetlights we had the
opportunity from the millenia before
that to experience a starry night sky
and invited us an inspiration and an awe
[Music]
when you are out under the night sky in
the dark next year family there's
nothing like it feel close to each other
and to really connect on a different
level than you were during the day
International dark-sky Association is a
not-for-profit organization based out of
Tucson Arizona that works all around the
world to protect the natural nighttime
environment and one of the most
important things that we do is education
and outreach look up is a sentiment that
reminds me that we are more than just
the world we inhabit the problem that is
associated with light pollution is only
really come about in a little more than
the last hundred years for everybody
there's really something to to see and
to learn just by going outside and
looking up at night
kids have a natural curiosity for
stargazing it is not hard to get them
excited or interested in this activity
what's the name of the brightest star in
the night sky every kid that comes out
here has a first-hand experience with
nature they are explorers my favorite
thing about space is that there's lots
of stars it's important to do stuff like
this because it's fun and it's
interesting it's different than looking
at it from like your balcony because you
can see it from what it really is I
haven't done anything like this before
I like that there's so many things that
we don't know about it we only know so
little and we can keep exploring it's
important for parents and kids to
definitely get out put the screens down
you know get back to nature
not only building memories but you're
deepening your connection was you know
the earth that we live in the idea of
being able to explore the natural
nighttime environment is something
that's really special to humanity
throughout our entire history led to
wandering exploring and discovering
things we had never contemplated before
where do we come from what are we made
of what's gonna happen to us in the
future I think the night sky can teach
kids a lot about our place in the world
and it connects them with something
that's beyond just our experience here
on earth
Thank You eye-dea Thank You National
Geographic part of starstruck a
year-long celebration of space
[Music]